what's with the jeans welcome to your
mom's house everybody oh ho mommy's here
and today i'm christina pazsitzky hey
I'm Tom Segura and the fabulous and
today we have a very special guest a
mommy mommy
an honorary mommy ful who's a huge fan
of rat please welcome mr. Earl Skakel
and Earl you know all the words to that
song I'm imagining ideas written by
Stephen Pearcy and Robin Crosby the late
Robin Crosby Earl is a fellow stand-up
comedian
yeah those who who are getting the known
for the first time is a huge rat fan
well I'd say metal savant
semaj hockey fanatic absolutely swing
wrestling Mme Mme and a comedic
wunderkind of you will yes how you doing
girl
I listen hearing rat this early in the
day
almost got me hard Wow we're gonna stick
with that come themed I guess for the
whole show I've even been on regular
radio in a while so no can I tell you a
little trivia little little something
about that song what it does for me yeah
so about five six years ago I was i I
booked a commercial campaign to be a
spokesman for Subway and the campaign
was that I was gonna play Jarrod's
brother no way yeah so very relaxed
brother cuz derelict brother
Jarrod can only was only could only be
used to advertise like healthy stuff
right so there was only like eat this uh
it's uh it's low in calories like you
know whatever the turkey seven and
they're like well we also have a
meatball sub and a chicken parm and we
can't use him to do that because it's
not so they're like what if we get
another guy it'll be his brother and his
brother can be like like Jerry could be
like I'm gonna have this turkey slab and
then we'll
had to like Tom sounds like I'm going to
meatballs that kind of shit right like
that's my husband so I booked it and
they're like it's a it was a big
contract we're gonna shoot a minimum of
ten commercials and so we go I shoot two
of them and I the first thing is they go
so the character's name is Jerome and I
was like drinking the time yeah hey
Jesse that's a Rome I was like yeah I go
this that's like you know it doesn't
really fit like I don't feel like a
major rome and they're like you know
what you're right they're like it but
they're like it sounds too black and I
was like yeah kind of yeah kind of like
so we renamed it to Jermaine perfect
less black so the first the first
commercial that we shoot is a is Jared's
family reunion in New Jersey and I pull
up I'm like I crashed my car into like
like like rocks and then I get out of
the car but as I pull up I am listening
to round and round and I had to memorize
I know I didn't know the song I had to
memorize it and mouth the lyrics so as I
drove up like I pull up and I'm like
totally rockin out but that means that
they licensed rats round and round for a
subway at the cost they did well never
air but I'm sure so you filmed it and it
never aired I filmed the two of them I
never see it never saw it but here's the
thing is that at the time they were like
this is gonna be like oh they were like
Lindahl they're like you'll you're
you're not gonna be able to go anywhere
without I mean like it's gonna be one of
those commercial campaigns that just
runs over and over and yeah like I mean
there was things in my contract like I
couldn't eat other fast food places see
anything yeah I couldn't go to like
McDonald's how long ago was this this
was 2000
like oh five the summer of oh five do
you think it was the rat the song that
they were like fuck we can't afford this
this is gonna be way too expensive
actually I know exactly what happened
the the senior VP of Marketing and this
happens a lot of times in the in
corporate world and stuff and an
entertainment he resigned like
the end of like it was just like his ear
to music I'm retiring and when I when
the new guy came in you never want to
take over somebody else's creative right
right cuz if it's good though we would
give the credit to the old guy and if
it's bad they'll be like well you should
have fucking done away with it so
usually what they do is they just kill
everybody in creative and they start
over so I got killed but I always I mean
it was a bummer at the time because so
much money but it was like your life
would have been completely different
probably because that could have taken
off where you're like the next
scrappy-doo but you know it's like I
would be like here all these years later
everybody would still be like eat fresh
and I probably would never like I
wouldn't be taken seriously like I'm
sure ever going out for gigs like acting
gigs stand-up people would probably just
all the time but once you sub it would
just be ridiculous in the long run it's
better
damn I want to see it though I wish
there was a see away blu-ray DVD special
like I hope there's a subway movie I did
try to contact the the ad agency and I'm
sure I can it exists somewhere somebody
has something it's a blessing in the
skies guys way up there but rat could
have been back on TV
it would have been prominently featured
to it can I tell you that video when I
came out I may have been like eight or
nine years old and you know the video of
there's a girl in the gray bodysuit and
she like kind of doesn't she tear it off
or she's like stretching around on the
table she was a human rat rat was into
concept videos by the way just said that
like I'm gonna I'm gonna teach you how
stupid you are
yeah it was like a professor and like
his freshman was like what what if he's
like listen stupid yeah cranking out
Night Ranger videos they were into the
storyline yeah how did you reserve
something that just what did metal just
resonate with you like the first time
you heard it yeah I just was you know
you don't have to think when you listen
to mouth
poisonous a nun skinny box that baseline
yeah you know I don't really understand
what Weezer singing about so it just
clicked with you man yeah it's the
videos were great I mean Tawny Kitaen
spreading the legs great Tawny Kitaen
still going to stand-up shows all the
time boy she goes to the Irvine improv
all the time yeah and the comedy stores
you go to the store too you just got
some relations with several comics
really find out are you see I won't name
names yeah I know two in particular
really attractive ones cool no not ready
you know I can't I don't want to say but
they're you know once dad yeah I can't
say I don't know how I got it I already
got it i deciphered it I won't say it
cuz he doesn't want to say Brody
Stephens Brody Stephens no Brody
Brody's asexual yes fuck it
I've never seen him with a girl in ten
years is he a sexual all he talks about
her is acne scars but here's the thing
I think cuz I have seen I've actually
ruined Stephen Brody Stephens game once
we were we were at The Improv in the
hallway and he was talking to some sweet
hot babe and I was like I know doubt
when I see him cuz I'm a huge Pro D
Stevens fan and I was like trying to get
his approval and I could see the look on
his face was like you fucked this up for
me like I was making progress I was
talking to this girl so I don't know I
don't know I think I don't think Brody's
whole life is a mystery to me and I want
to know more I feel like I need to know
him it would be great I don't think you
did fuck up his game cuz he was probably
just dropping baseball names to this
girl who's Andre Ethier yes well first
of all we we didn't catch up with our
mommies yeah well mommy you were in
North Carolina
oh this past weekend yeah yeah I did
well I went to Atlanta first I did the
Buckhead Theatre on Thursday yes we did
it with Rory Scovel
I know if you know Rory very funny
gentlemen from
he's from originally South Carolina
there's an L a really funny guy and Carl
labove a comedy store veteran legend of
the store if you will from the Kinison
days and yeah it was great we had a
blast great turnout and then we went to
Asheville North Carolina for the laughs
your Asheville off comedy festival isn't
it it's a play on words I got it it's so
hard to come up with names for comedy I
know for clubs it's never like when you
hear especially like the independent
names like when you think about the
comic store is a great name yeah or it
makes sense
it's the Comedy Store then there's you
know there's like there's Rascals
there are giggles and side splitters and
like dr. grins that are in yeah I like
the wet spot there is no houston
Wisconsin rooster teeth feathers
that's a terrible what's the one what's
the one further up there pepper bellies
yeah Tommy tease ya Tommy cheese is one
it's also a steakhouse it's like you get
like free most steak at that place
really yeah it's like a grade-a
steakhouse and comedy fun there's very
few comedy clubs that have great food
like Manhattan Beach County magic they
have really good food there that's worth
also a ridiculous name for a place no
it's from the 20s yeah yeah isn't a
hugger
yeah I thought you might have private
bars I think of titties when I think of
flappers right she's got big old
flappers on her now I know I don't know
I think a Janey
oh but the comedy festival was great
it's really really fun I highly
recommend if you you know if you're a
comic
getting into that thing submitting
or whatever and it was great man it's
like it it feels way there I've done a
bunch of festivals now and it was the
first one that's like you feel like it's
a community based thing like it's very
small it's really accessible your face
painted in show you can do that I did by
I did buy some of fresh freshly made
like sweetened walnuts
mmm not like like in the little fare
kind of playground area did you like the
Carolinas cuz I love the Carolina
college there oh yeah no idea yeah yeah
of course it's great man I mean the
people are super friendly Asheville is
like it has that split between like
gross hippies and then like genuine
outgoing nice Carolina people or so like
every time you're like oh you're
disgusting they need me someone who's
only there was this I honestly did this
there were so many people that had
intense Bo that like because they're
like there's those hippies like will
really embrace that like I'm never
showering that like the second day I'm
walking down the street it's really nice
to walk around in Asheville like really
nice trees and like parks and we're like
city squares that have like you know all
kinds of like homeless fountains there'd
be some of that but then I'm crossing
the street and I stand there and I get a
whiff ah like if I can I really strong
we're like you're you're you can't help
your face kind of moves on its own and
your eyes start to flutter a little but
I turn to the guy next to me and I just
it I didn't think about it I go is that
you dude he didn't know what I was
talking about and I was like come on man
and then I realized that right basically
behind him where there was a trio a lot
of like folk singers and stuff to set up
shop you know and they'll just play
they'll play like three of them will
play like sing on a corner and it was
one of them that just it was basically
like a white guy that had not showered
so long that he had brown like 10th to
him like it was pretty
but you should carry around that used to
carry around that little spritzer bottle
in your pocket all the time yeah truly
smell it reminds me of college because I
went to school in San Francisco smell of
Haight Street like you walk down Main
Street desired weed or acid or whatever
and and you it to me it smells like like
dirty hippie girls with dreadlocks yes
it's like if if you haven't showered in
your box is filthy like I just imagined
that their box is just dirty and
patchouli covers the filth it doesn't
really matter tea box and patchouli you
know it's the fucking like who likes the
smell the smell of crab per pee yeah
it's a smell of it you know what it's a
smell of not trying in life yeah it
really is it's the smell of I gave up
before it started yeah that's the kind
of girls I go for now did you grow up
here in Los Angeles video you've always
lived here
yeah I grew up in the hills of bel-air
did you really well I tell people that
and everyone thinks I'm loaded you know
my dad bought the house in the 50s when
bel-air was like nothing more than
Culver City and yeah it just grew up and
then you know OJ was my neighbor no no
Kareem Oh Jay used to throw me the
football no no no are you being serious
I'm dead serious
wait how far down that he lived from you
he live like maybe six houses down
seriously did you for murdering when
together no it was cool with me I mean
he always was nice to my sister so you
didn't have any issues with blondes back
then was it just crushing pussy like
they just be different him and James
Caan we're down the street and Kareem
with jog you know and it's like dolphin
shorts and this is like bel-air in the
70s we you didn't really see black guys
in bel-air yet so see a seven-foot -
you're black - around half nude was
really set the neighbors off we're like
would they go what's going on with that
black well base it was like an alien I
mean
yes Kareen - looked like looks right
didn't we get on the shuttle yeah at the
CVG Cincinnati Northern Kentucky Airport
he's a big old son-of-a-bitch
yeah he's a 7-footer he's
strange-looking humanoid and you know I
mean they're literally were no black
people in bel-air cannabis
I mean the guy who took me to school we
got pulled over several times by the
cops because they thought he was
kidnapping me he was dark-skinned he was
like Dikembe Mutombo black pull that mic
a little closer - he was like a uh I
don't want to say Butler that's that's a
bit dismissive but I was a butler but it
talks to me like youyou did have money
growing up I mean well I mean we weren't
poor well it's great if you can get one
so you this guy that he live at the
house yeah my dad was one business a lot
so we had a Leroy what's his name no it
wasn't
Leroy Prince and he was like your your
Manny yeah he took us to school and
whipped up some real good food you know
bacon for a lot of fried food yes weird
the neighborhood like do anything creepy
do you like when they ate could never
tell your parents like well I had a
tutor a big titted tutor oh this baby
goes to your baked it fat it's possible
but you know my brother had this big
tattoo tutor and I mean they were huge
and there was a possible molestation and
I was supposed to get her like the week
after he was done with her and and he
told my mom and so I got this some guy
named Harold yeah you still give a crank
him out to her oh absolutely yeah I
crank them out - Harold - no what was
your father what did he do for a living
that my dad really was an amazing guy he
was on the cover of Life magazine what
he was like Jacques Cousteau before you
know Jacques Cousteau he was like killed
whales with his bare hands
and he was like a soldier of fortune he
being serious yeah yeah is in the
sixties if you look up James Skakel he
was on the you know and this was when
life was like at the only magazine out
there so a big deal and so wait he was a
like a treasure hunter that was one part
of his life and explore like an explorer
like we don't really have a guy like
that and yeah today's that was your
father
yeah and then he had his business side
where he his dad in the depression would
drive by oil refineries and buy their
waste and he would turn it into graphite
so that's that's buku right but then he
lost all his money he went deep on this
oil project in the Amazon and if it
would have had we would have been
billionaires but it didn't have life who
are you or else Cagle know this about
you thank you for edible then yeah do
you think I tell these stories at open
mikes and North Hollywood this is
incredible so you have how many siblings
you have of two brothers two sisters big
family I'm the baby oh wow and what's
your mother about she uh issues with
like a house housewife you know she was
a very uh they died two months apart
it's very romantic
really and yeah in a weird was it
recently 98 okay so it's not to be first
the family dog died of 21 years uh-huh
and this dog should have been put down
alone you know he had like when I fall
out what my mom just stuck it back
scooped it yeah we didn't believe in
that's our daughter home medicine I mean
we had one dog named Messier Hill had so
many ailments I had to take him because
no one else wanted them when they died
so I took him to the vet and he
literally had like a ten page medical
report he had like cirrhosis of the
liver and oh my god you know but I
nursed him back to a nice life really
that named after the hockey player yeah
of course yeah wait so
were you aware like I always wondered
this when when people have extremely
accomplished parents or a parent like
you know like really like a like a
suspect like an iconic kind of are you
aware at a certain like what age are you
aware that like dad is not just like
every other dad you know well uh you
know here's another like whacky
sideline of my family's is his sister's
Ethel Kennedy so what who was married to
Bobby shuttle that's his sister as his
sister's still alive so you know two
wacky family but not really I mean it's
my marriage Bobby Kennedy this was you
know Ethel's husband right so that would
have been your uncle yeah by marriage so
I don't know you're marrying into the
Kennedy Valley yeah dad is basically a
Jacques Cousteau that's crazy it's a
wacky I mean my dad was like a scratch
golfer you know he was just like were
you guys close you know my daddy was
kind of like a superhero you didn't
really talk to him unless he came to you
so yeah quiet guy but uh I was more
close with my mom it was like a country
bumpkin
Cartersville Georgia oh and his and your
dad was was he from otago from Chicago
so he was the guy though that like if
ever you could have been like I'm in
Libya he'd be like let me call Qaddafi
real quick no I've got some he knew he
knew guys in every parts of the world oh
yeah I mean he was but the great thing
about my dad was he was friends with
billionaires and golf caddies and he
chanted in the same so yeah I mean he
was a member up at bel-air Country Club
which is a really uh you know foo-foo
kind of place and he would show up with
a shirt inside out mustard stains on it
you know underwear hanging out you know
he was some maniac that's awesome did
did you know when you were a kid like
who oj was when he's throwing you the
ball I mean I knew he was the Hertz guy
Hertz guy you know it was I didn't
really know it's football prowess ya
know that's the Heisman Trophy winner
right yeah
I mean but he was so nice to me throw me
the football and Stallone was lived down
the street and this is when he lived
with Susan Anton you know she was that
like that tall blonde and you know he'd
have a lot of girls over his house
sure you know do you remember any
growing up do you remember any crazy
stories like all that one day and a
carrot top did this or that was there
anything that you remember that sticks
out that was just like growing up in
Hollywood well right next door to us was
Harry Nilsson who was like a legendary
like a 70s folk singer like he wrote
songs with the Beatles
he would always crash his car into
Arcade you know he was he got shit-faced
I mean he wasn't food I mean he was a
loser I mean his face was so red I mean
it's like it was another planet but you
know it was just normal you know seeing
that no no really wacky stuff there was
we had a neighbor who was a swinger oh
no how did you know you could just tell
you know he would always have girls
around him in bikinis and it was a
different girl each week and he was kind
of a wacky guy I think it was a coat
deal or two that's so intense you know
what's interesting is that comedians
generally come from at least like a
lower socioeconomic or
like Hard Knocks definitely super at
least ya know a lot of last week his
dad's a professional gambler it's good
it's the opposite for Earl it sounds
like you came from a pretty affluent
like accomplished privileged privileged
also was born lucky
very rare then privileged cuz yeah like
my dad you know when I say bel-air
Country Club people think wow you know
like today I think it costs 200 grand to
be a member there but my dad joined it
was like $1500 so and you know the house
was now would probably sell for eight
nine million but back then I think he
bought it for like 300 he was just luck
that everywhere he went he bought low
and sold high
sorry girl
this is no it's an interruption not no
need you know by trying to be rude but
it is a exclusive dental update here on
your mom's house Christina what's going
on I do have a dental update who this we
started doing this feature while back
about three months ago Tom and I were
undergoing massive dental issues I have
an issue
guys I think I might have a fucking
cavity how's this possible so bad I know
you just you had we were at the dentist
you had everything taken care of
everything was examined x-rays what's
going on well I was I'm on Weight
Watchers and so I've been eating yes
thank you right man thank you I'm trying
to be a disgusting Pig which we'll talk
about later but I was eating some
veggies cold out of the fridge and I
noticed some pain I might up her fucking
tooth in my jaw and then I drank water
and it was it was hurting again so I'm a
little cautious now it might just be a
heat and cold sensitivity which I've had
on other teeth and I'm hoping it will
pass well usually that comes from
something bad tooth problem though when
you have like we're cold sensitivity I
gotta tell you I'm really disappointed
right now I'm so mad I just was there I
mean I thought you would take care of
them after week I've been brushing and
flossing do you floss her off I do I get
a wacky dentist story
what's your dental update well I was
reading this book about kiss and Paul
Stanley talked about this great Dennis
Brandt was so like oh I'll go this guy
so I go in there for the exam and he
hands me an estimate for $18,000 what
dr. Stan golden of grant what you got if
you're filthy loaded I mean 18 grand
worth of work if they're all new teeth
basically and he said we can start today
and I'm like no we can't he wanted to
give me a $3,000 mouth guard to sleep in
what is the most crazy thing I've ever
heard of my life that's bullshit I have
a dental update oh I was in Montana for
the weekend unfortunately I mean
fortunately
Montana's great it's beautiful but
everyone there is like you know hiding
from the law there's a better hotel
there was like these two guys that got
off a motorcycle with like a three year
old girl and in the he's and they were
like they go to the front desk and I
just happen to be walking behind him
they were like we need a room and
they're like two beds or one they're
like one and I'm like what the fuck is
going on here don't look him in the eye
just walk to your room you know anyways
the only place that was nearby we didn't
have a car so we had to live off eating
at McDonald's for three days which is
the grossest fucking place ever the
vacations no no no this was Miss Taylor
but so there was only a McDonald's there
so we actually had to live eating
McDonald's gross we lived on there was
like a gas station right next to and a
McDonald's that's all we had yeah oh
yeah I shit out Pringles it was horrible
but the guy at McDonald's there was a
manager at McDonald's I mean he was
general manager II was there every
single day and this dude had six teeth
and they were all trying to escape his
body and they were pointing out of his
mouth so he couldn't even shut his lips
and they weren't like you know when you
see little UCT he had it where there was
no gum so where was like these long
teeth that looked like that like the
size of your little finger just sticking
out of his mouth and his lips just
rested on it and so when he was just
like like we did we rang up sup we're
trying to get an iced coffee with a
low-fat milk but you can't do that there
I guess but so he when he was like
thinking or when he has his mouth closed
it just looked like his mouth with like
five dots like heads sticking out of it
not just his teeth that we're trying to
we're pointing out that direction that's
rough dude can I Montana is a horrible
no it's not a horrible it's a beautiful
landscape but the I did a Tribble around
there yeah my first time featuring was a
Tribble run which we said we talked
about this last week yeah yeah a Tribble
run is bugged by a guy named David
Tribble
and they're essentially two weeks of
hell gigs and you're driving eight hours
of fucking day to get to some asshole
and your biker bars and button in the
hotel we said he booked us in a hotel
that was that had been shut down for
prostitution not two weeks before that
that's the Tribble run and Montana I was
in I think Butte and I was at a biker
bar and I bombed harder than I've ever
bombed in my life you should burn
through the night yes and it was one of
those bombings
that I went to the alleyway and started
crying and I was like I need a quick
comedy like it was one of those sets
where you're like I'm questioning
everything I've ever done up until this
point it was so terrible so that's my
Montana I have a question of you guys
know this if you guys know any do you
guys have any education on two-way
mirrors because the hotel we were
staying at is it was very awkward see I
went there with my girlfriends a feature
dancing there at this place called
teasers which was a nice place it was
like this the strip club in the middle
of nowhere and it was attached to a bar
it was pretty cool but the the hotel was
oddly really far away and like there was
like nicer hotels closer and everything
but weird this hotel in the middle you
know opposite direction
I just found it odd like everybody in
the hotel kind of like had like this
kind of weird would they come pick you
up then yeah it was it's just like being
a comic it's like what being a featured
dancer it's the exact same thing as
being comics they pick you up at the
airport you have to go do radio yet you
know he's all that crazy sweet but as a
featured is a headliner dancer no no
that's that is yeah they're the feature
in the feature and so it was kind of odd
like the front desk person was just like
so do you guys get a lot of people there
last night like it was like how do you
even know that though yeah so it was
kind of weird so we getting into this
room and I'm thinking like alright this
is like their version of I like the
comics room like a comedy condo but
oddly there was like this long mirror
that was right around the bed that looks
so awkward like it was a black mirror
like it wasn't like a normal mirror it
was like had this black tint to it
and I'm like trying to do like I thought
there was like a trick where you put
your finger on the mirror and if there's
like a depth between your finger and the
reflection of your finger that supposed
to mean that there's you know like it's
a souvenir yeah but but my girlfriend's
like no there's better mirror technology
nowadays it's harder to detect here's
something so now I don't know if you
guys thought it was 2a though yeah the
whole time I'm thinking
there's there's like a room next to us
and that's how we're the McDonald's
managers like yeah and I'm thinking like
all the Hyatt somebody have like I like
stadium seating on the other side of the
micro tel and they're just like fucking
sitting in there like all right oh man
do this is it like is it weird like so
you got to go do you go to the club
every night with her yeah well the first
night I didn't because I was just too
tired but the other two nights I did and
do they treat you like there's a staff
like oh you're with her that's cool
they're nice yeah they were really nice
staff but what I found weird is how the
the staff treats the girls is not like
how a manager treats the feature comic
you know it's more like no you're
working for me and you're doing exactly
what you know it was it was like what
kind of still like you're gonna go you
have dances yeah you're going to go in
here and you're gonna play game with
cooter ball and and if you don't plays
you know it's like she's like what
scooter ball and that's like where you
take the shot glass put in between your
tits and then you have them shoot
rolled up money and they try to which
makes sense like if you're if you're if
you're at a strip club and a bunch of
guys are drunk like the best way to put
get money on the stage is play a game
that has something to do with sports
yeah you know but yeah it's like they
kind of made it was more like no you're
working for us kind of really it's so
interesting that she's a good attitude
about it
yeah yeah I mean because honestly you
know she made a shitload of money from
it you should like it like in 15 minutes
I was like in the greenroom like she's
like kidding you know you know like here
I'll I'll you put all this money
together for you and it was like I just
retard it like I tweeted a photo of it
it was just retarded least acts of money
and it's just like holy shit this is so
much fucking money that's just tip yeah
and and you know what's weird is like
you don't think about this but a girl
works for you know three days they look
like they just fucking robbed a bank and
there's you know in the middle of
nowhere there's not her Bank of America
anywhere near so she has to travel with
all his money it looks like we were
fucking bank robbers now just a tip out
do the girls with the tip oh yeah yeah
she tips she I don't know if you're
supposed to but she tipped everybody
every single person that worked at that
club she tipped really yeah
ya know obviously it's under the radar
too like there's no tax yeah well I
think she claimed he's got a claim I
think she has to claim its toes or
something like that no that's I want to
I want to go on this for a long time but
I wanted to get back to we know that
much time Weight Watchers and I tell you
I gain like 15 pounds this year on the
road just eating like mozzarella sticks
and Chardonnay and shit just being alone
like you know you're so lonely and I
would just eat like bowls and mac and
cheese and just sleep I woke up one time
with a lunchable like a thing a cheese
next to my head like one morning like it
was just it's bad so I've been doing
Weight Watchers which is fucking awesome
in red bands of it sue you done it I
lost 70 pounds when we last three months
I tell you one of the worst things about
the best thing about Weight Watchers is
the meetings like I don't care what
people say you have to go to these
meetings where all that you know you
talk and give advice like hey you know
there's like turkey bacon and pavilions
and it's only two points and stuff like
that so it's kind of cool to like learn
new tips but I like because I got really
baked before I used to go and and it was
just a bunch of women you know and a
couple fat guys in the corner and you
know but but like and but the problem
was is I started losing so much weight
because I kind of hacked Weight Watchers
I don't need to like you don't eat like
half the points I was supposed to eat
and like I just wanted to lose weight
super fast so although the people
started to resent me really they have
like these like ribbon ceremonies every
week we're like well Brian lost five
more pounds so he gets another ribbon
and a keychain and people would resent
you for real yeah it was like openly no
but you could tell these people were
just giving me these looks like what the
fuck this is the second ribbon in a row
this guys won two weeks you did half the
points yeah what I did is see when your
own weight watchers you get a certain
amount of points based on your weight
and I you know if you're male or female
or whatever and in those point dick
points are like you know like a turkey
sandwiches like six points or whatever
you know who cares what I would do is I
would only eat half the points and I
would eat tons of vegetables so I would
eat I would get this huge bowl like a
salad bowl and fuck up chop up every
single vegetable I can think of and then
I'll get a one point tortilla
and just make like burritos out of
vegetables you know so I was just
getting stuffed as much as I can on
vegetables because vegetables are zero
points for the most part and then I
would have like 15 points for the whole
day and I'd be like okay now I have 15
points I'm gonna have like a fucking
lean pocket or something yeah you know
so I the biggest secret I could give is
just eat shit loads of vegetables until
years I can't fucking breathe anymore
I'm so stuffed with vegetables and then
you won't even eat half your points like
I was very smart
my problem is alcohol because I like to
drink like two glasses of wine and a
that's no problem but that's like 14
points what yeah I'll call is high it's
like four wine
six points Berg I thought what if I wine
was two or four points unless they
change they said they just changed the
whole point that let's be honest let's
be honest you like to drink a lot more
than no I took Tommy breakfast usually
has last one I drink the brandy like
that guy on intervention I got the best
new drink by the way guys it's this
vodka it's called I think it's called
pinnacle but it's a pinnacle and it has
like they have like five different like
flavors and one of the flavors is cream
and it's just like I taste like ice
cream or something
but you mix it with diet root beer it
tasted you a root beer float Wow it's
the most dangerous drink in the world
oh no root beer floats are good yeah I
I've always been I've always fluctuated
and struggled with weight like I've gone
I've been in tip-top shape before like
where it's like you know you can't get
in that much better shape and I've been
like an absolute human piece of shit
yeah right now I'm like I'm definitely
fat and overweight and need to lose
weight but I'm not anywhere now I'm like
I'm 230 you know I mean I'm stronger
than I've been in a long time so I've
been hitting the weights pretty hard I
definitely need to lose weight but it's
always a thing like it's it's it's
definitely like I'm not one of the
people who's like those people just go
through life like same sorry you look
like you're fucking a shape this is
cankles ripped I worked out like two
hours every day
how many days a week every day pretty
much seven days a week for the most part
Wow do you know I just got a great
jawline to look at that but just know
there's no face meat hanging off you I
think it's very strong he's a machine I
take a lot of diuretics and laxatives
now were you were you and haffley in
school afternoon like middle school high
school all that stuff that you compete
in sports in grade school I was like the
Jewish Shaq I mean I was just dominated
cuz I've been the same size since the
third grade I mean my doctor thought I
was gonna be like seven feet really I
was a huge kid and you know and then I
got to high school and I never met
anyone my age bigger than me and there
were these two black kids on the
football team my age I was like wow I
looked at them like they were aliens cuz
cuz they're black well yeah bel-air I
mean I went to grade school in Beverly
Hills you know I mean that was locked
down first in the seventies this
different era now but so my mom wouldn't
sign the death certificate for the
football team because you know she saw
them she's like those guys might cry
she's like wow it's like that scene in
Fast Times with it we're like are you
flying for the game you know so I was an
athlete but I didn't get to play sports
I was on the golf team okay there's like
what then did you only in Beverly Hills
is there a golf team what yeah what the
fuck man I grew up in it in the valley
we didn't have any of that actually and
so did the other school down the street
they had a golf team - but that's
Florida I think Beach
you know yeah these big golf yeah
there's no cholos in bel-air we had a
Ski Club
Eschete ski really yeah we used to go
skiing once a week no shit wait where's
that wasn't kohai oh yeah yeah I don't
think there would be a ski yeah it's no
wait so did you um but did you stay you
were always active like were you lifting
and running in high school even if
you're not on a team yeah it was
probably the best team to get best time
to get laid you know yeah working out
you know I just probably overcome it
stated and you know at but then I was on
the golf team I really wasn't a good
golfer but they want to play my dad's
Country Club
so they they put me on the team so we
could practice that that's just so you
have great habits it sounds like yeah
that's a big thing who's disciplined you
I cannot believe how much weight you
lost
I actually went a long time I think
without seeing you at one point and it
might have been during that where I saw
you before you had done it right and
like you know I was just like oh he's
just you're a chubby dude
and then the next time I saw you I did
not even recognize you I was like it was
like you'd been melted oh yeah I
flexibly a lot like right now I'm kind
of on the way up to gaining weight way
especially since I McDonald's Montana
yeah no you know I I've gotten to a
point where I eat healthy Weight
Watchers is the best of year struggling
for weight because not only does Weight
Watchers work but it really gets in your
brain and helps you like when you're I'm
out I'll be like I'm like oh here you
know I want to eat a burger so bad but
no man is no I don't want any cheese
like you're thinking like all these
things you normally don't think of you
know like oh that's four points that's
two points so it really helps and I
still do that but I don't know once you
get used to eating like low-fat versions
of shit and just like low-fat cheese as
opposed to getting like the full fat
absolutely yeah little things like that
really I definitely have to have some
structure I realized - no no it's like I
mean I've like I've been home I go to
the gym because I figured out like if I
if I just kind of wing it I guess it's
not gonna work for me you know what's
hard on the road all the roads that's
very and got me man yeah cuz like you're
in an airport so your day starts at 5:00
a.m. or four am you go to the airport
you get on a flight you land somewhere
in the middle of fuck well don't forget
before at that Airport if you're like
I'm fuckin hungry that's gonna suck
right it's usually like Mickey D's or
something or a bakery cpk yeah and
you've got that La Brea bakery in the
Delta yeah and and that's it so now
you're eating a piece of shit to get on
a plane and then now you're in the
Midwest you're in a hotel where there's
nothing around you you have no car cuz
you can't afford a rent-a-car cuz you're
not making that much money yep so now I
go down to the hotel and I'm in the
Midwest they don't fucking the iceberg
lettuce and ranch you know that's the
salad and everything else is like ribs
or cheesy beef or whatever the fuck
there was just no way to do it like some
killed me and McDonald's will kill you
too eating that shit yeah yeah yeah it's
it is rough there's no gym I mean
usually a lot of places don't have the
gym and then it's really easy to like
you can also you can make that displayed
second kind of thing where you go like
when you arrive and you're like I'm
fucking tired and you decide like if
let's say they do have a gym you like am
I gonna go work out or might I'm gonna
take a nap right now you take that nap
and then you wake up from a nap or
you're like I gotta get something to eat
before the show and then you've talked
yourself out of working out that day you
know I mean it's like it's a it's an
endless thing where you can easily get
to to talk yourself out of doing
anything travel takes out of me period
like I'm sure you're in a different time
zone you're not in your element
so you're just put hired more for some
reason when you're trapped all of this
came to our attention because last night
watching we're watching TV and we had we
caught the world's fattest man yeah and
there's a it's a Brit now and now
they're passing a torch it used to be
Manuel rebei who we found out about
through also through Discovery Channel
or TLC thank you and Manuel is the hands
he's the king he's Mexican those are his
tits those are just he has gradually
balloon to the weight of six and a Half
Men
what is that it's a tumor that look like
balls it is
those are leg balls he has a wife by the
way into normal society okay listen to
this
what is life on the inside really like
for the world's heaviness man oh my bad
James is this where it lists petits 2008
with over 2 million people is the
country's industrial heartland it is
also home to 42 year-old men well 3 be
mourning for Manuel starts with his
daily grooming routine don't groom he
says I like doing my hair looking nice
five years this has been Manuel's only
view he not only sleeps in this bed he
washes here to pee and make love are the
best things to go to the toilet starting
each morning with a hot breakfast oh my
god
what is that
so he's washing down is played a fool of
the Sodapop morning leave this room this
is actually what goes into how he got
fat first we go to the states and then
he he goes to us and he gets a desk job
and he's like basically I work next door
to a pizza shop and I eat beads all day
so this is on the pizza shop I think
right there yeah that's where he went he
went to Texas that's more than but look
look that's him right there
okay big dude just a food you know what
all food that we all like but that we
all put the brakes on sometimes because
all at the same time that's where he's a
big fat piece of shit
so he's 500 pounds there and that's he
doubles that he fucking doubles that
shit you're seeing now he's over a grand
oh my god but that's when you say well I
think when you're at five large you kind
of go okay wait a minute I'm bedridden
maybe I should slow it down it looks
pretty good there yeah it's a gross fat
tumors in his legs and they have to
operate to get the fat tumors out I was
in Vegas a couple weeks ago and I saw a
guy that was like pretty fat like he had
that came in and his the one his one of
his legs look like had one of these
tumors where like the back of his leg
just had this extra on the back of it
and he's a sat there and was at a rest
it was like a rest stop gas station and
he had a slot machine he was just
sitting there playing slots over and
over again
how does this guy who could barely even
walk to sit here make play slots all day
how's he keep money to they even do this
yeah well we wondered that too well what
happened was the new guy is not this guy
this guy lost some some weight the new
guy is a guy named Paul I forget it's a
Brit he's a British guy mm-hmm and so
he's the new Pig of the world who well
I'm just trying to describe him but he
they didn't think they could get him to
the hospital because they didn't think
they had the hospital install it or the
bed and so you know what they did they
they're like whit they figured out that
I will have him here at this hospital in
England we don't think the floors can
support him so they had to reinforce the
floors they put steel columns on all
these points so that he would be resting
at and they were they had a successful
surgery and now they're gonna follow up
we haven't seen the follow-up but a it's
incredible and actually you know it
brought to my mind on a much smaller
scale but still you might know who he is
Earl Nate Newton do you remember Nate
Newton Dallas Cowboy yes have you seen
his before-and-after yeah he's if he was
a big guy but he smoked a lot of pot oh
yeah but he was also we'd make me fish
he he was I mean look at look at Nate he
was 400 he was four bills at one point
was that's him now that's him after
isn't it creepy when they do wait till
you see him look right here wait to see
him that's him say hi to Deon Naz do
that's it that's Nate Newton this Natan
in the red Oh oh my god yeah that's
pretty amazing dude look at him wait I
mean like really look at this guy he in
shape used to look like in his prime
time well now they're just showing look
at me look at him there
oh alright pause that can you go on
another thing open up
oops yeah there yeah there is no way Wow
dude he was a house though that's not
even doing judges a big way bigger than
that I mean I like it better bigger I
think I like I'm better bigger fat
people though I'm very pretty you do an
image a Google image shirt search of
Nate Newton we sure can any but look at
that guy I mean he really lost at all
it's really incredible now tell him how
he lost it though didn't you tell me
yesterday crystal meth no yeah I mean
but like the guy he was a house man he's
a house yeah that's him with the chips
he was like deep frigerator Perry he was
the kitchen that's what they called him
in kitchen to the kitchen yeah but the
frigerator he the whole kitchen like
look at that guy man number 61 was a big
that's a big motherfucker yeah and he
was he's playing at 3:33 40 but he would
get up to three ninety four hundred you
know like in the offseason yeah he was a
monster of a human being but he did oh
so here's the thing oh this way you're
talking about baby so you know real
sports you ever watch real oh I love
that show
so they did a profile on basically
linemen who after after they play you
know like you play let's say you play
your linemen you play at three three ten
or something right then you're done and
if you decide not to take that down to
that totally unnecessary weight to like
a more manageable weight like to thirty
to forty they're like if you're not
doing you know if you're if you don't
take it down then it's really easy to
snowball the other way right like sure
right because you're not running you're
not lifting it you don't have that that
football regimen so these guys are are
getting up to like four bills and then
after that it's just a lifetime of
health problems so they profiled a
couple guys show these guys that I'd
really like just they're out of control
now and they don't know whether they're
one of them died shortly like the right
the next day after the interview he died
and they showed Nate Newton and he was
basically like look
I'm never gonna stop eating like the way
I eat yeah I'll be out he's like the
only way that I can that I can
counterbalance what I eat is I exercise
like five hours a day now because I I
just I'm never gonna make like really
awesome decisions with these I'm just
gonna I'm gonna eat so I'm just gonna
exercise a lot more and that's the only
that was his like solution he had the
surgery but that's how he does it that's
how he maintains it now exercise like I
wish I liked exercise but I fucking hate
it I hate it
I've always been lazy my whole life so
like my only choice is just to not eat
shit and I feel like I'm you what I'm
Nate Newton I feel like just like Nate
knew but I feel like his philosophy is a
good one
that's when do you like your treats yeah
I like to eat food eat your treats you
can eat anything you want if you workout
enough yeah well just look at the like
the the example of that is you heard
about Phelps his diet right right
Michael Phelps swimmer well when he's
training he eats 12,000 calories every
weight oh my god really there's a lot
that's Manuel Uribe yeah have you seen
have you seen Phelps have you seen any
other sites a great body but you just
exercise is all you have you can you
pull up what he eats he's literally in a
pool all day like right half - no no but
it's it's the extreme example of of the
fuel for ready dude he absolutely needs
it you couldn't do what he does now
without that fuel but when you read what
he acted Michael Phelps talking about
well because it you know it's so
impressive to us because he looks so
lean and so efficient and yet it seems
that he eats like a garbage game let's
break down the meals for you okay so at
breakfast we have these three massive
egg sandwiches with all kinds of mayo
and tomatoes and all that stuff that's
part of breakfast he also has a five egg
omelet okay he will eat a bowl of grits
okay he will eat these chocolate chip
pancakes right
it's toner powder things okay if you
wash it down with two precious you see
these big ham sandwiches okay with all
kinds of crunchy gooey things inside of
them a pound of pasta a panels and
calories in energy drinks okay now
dinner time a full pizza another pound
of pasta and another thousand calories
are so busy even though do that it that
you like your stomach how does your like
yeah that seems impossible shit the pits
just have you ever done it where you
like you watch it and no one says
anything that makes them go faster a big
brown bomb yeah it's just it's
incredible what that is like have you
ever done where like you know you work
out and then you're like wow like like
an hour later look I'm actually much
more hungry now oh yeah like if you have
ever swam like if you you could swim
five minutes and it's like oh my god you
feel every muscle yeah working and
aching and burning it this guy swims
what like six hours a day like just it's
nonstop it's incredible man how old is
Phelps he's younger than us may 20 2014
how long can you be swimmer like when
does that end he's probably gonna do
this next Olympics and that would be his
that's that yeah cuz I know football
players man like when you retire you
just broken down right like just well
you don't hear you you know he crushed
no I mean you're not broke you're broke
if you're stupid no no no broken down Oh
broken down
oh they're completely focused done yeah
yeah now he can he can enjoy a nice long
life Phelps can swimming is a way to go
football it's just like not only is this
shit hurt but like you basically can end
up you basically end up retarded like so
they can't like they have they have they
have brains they they've examined brains
and they have like like an 85 year old
Alzheimer patients
Brown matter boxers
Oh boxing and MMA fighters to those guys
you've seen you seen what's his name
Anderson Silva like in an interview and
he's like yeah molester your heads
getting smashed well yeah for years
watch some of those interviews with the
guys who were in the first few us which
was unlimited when they're not unlimited
but rules yeah pretty much human
cockfighting you know no weight classes
yeah I enjoy gay porn every now yeah I
don't always enjoy gay porn this is this
has been super fun it's besides the
crane unfortunately it's not normally
like this we usually go for longer but
we have to wrap up that way but a CDL we
should let them oh yeah oh yeah yeah if
I could tell you guys how to download it
for free I was yeah it's very ghetto it
was done like rats EP is it's very
Motley Crue's EP very a self recorded
with my zoom digital recorder facing
away from the speakers Oh metal do
that's very very good
well yeah it's it's a garage recordings
at various where can we download a net
iTunes in Amazon you know it's so go to
iTunes is there a name for the album
Earl alive I totally ripped off kiss
alive alive its Earl Skakel okay a Kate
yeah and the album is called alive
so yeah Earl's hilarious I got to see
you open for Rob shower in Calgary you
were hilarious don't absolutely killed
it Skakel's the best and a great human
being and very funny you guys are the
best
so glad you came into my girl thanks for
doing this
Errol you have to do this again next
time yes we don't normally have a time
constraints yeah sorry skates yeah
because there's a million things I want
to ask you so I love you back we'll have
to bring you back
I love everyone in this room yes
part one of year you're gonna have
another one man definitely cell
absolutely I'm honored and humbled we'll
do this again alright see you guys see
you guys bye mom